i say um put mental health first because
if you don't then you're not going to
enjoy your sport and you're not going to
succeed as much as you want to so it's
okay sometimes to even sit out the big
competitions
to focus on yourself because it shows
how strong of a competitor and person
that you really are
rather than just battle through it
[Music]
we've seen increasingly that athletes
are getting comfortable with the idea of
discussing mental health
and the idea of you know treating their
you know state of mind their mental
health as kind of a body part in the
same way they would attend to a sprained
ankle or a pulled
hamstring that they are going to take
time to recover if they're feeling any
kind of
mental duress and i think it's a really
healthy and productive conversation to
have
teams and franchises and athletes and
coaches now treat
physical injury different than they did
a generation ago you know the idea of
like you know just icing somebody down
or like slapping them upside the head
and saying get back
out there and do it for the team is
increasingly
a fading notion uh and mental health is
sort of a new part of the prism here
the idea that teams would have an
investment in not just the mental health
that applies to their
execution on the playing field but just
their general
health and happiness is a new thing and
i think that
it actually in this case in an
interesting way has been athlete driven
it's the athletes who are coming forward
and talking with great candor
about their own struggles i think we're
just
a little bit too stressed out but we
should be out here having fun and
sometimes
that's not the case in the past we know
that
people have not talked about mental
health especially
in the public realm because there's so
much stigma
that exists and while that stigma still
exists we see
a lot of high profile athletes talking
about their mental health
on the clinical side we also see a lot
more cooperation with larger
organizations to try and understand what
it means to have a mental health
diagnosis
and what that might look like for their
individual athletes
a lot of people think that athletes just
appear
and show us their natural grace and
abilities
and while it's true many of them have
outstanding physical abilities
and we love watching them perform it
takes many many
hours to get them in that place of
mental toughness to be able to execute
their skills
on demand so i think that it's important
for people to understand that even
though they see that public
excellence sometimes there's quite a bit
of private anguish
it's important for people to realize
that these athletes are
humans first they have emotions they
have life's
outside of sport so it's important for
them to take care of themselves too
we've already seen in the conversation
that's happening and the elevation of
the topic
not just in sports but in you know
workplaces at large you know a real
benefit for people
to feel the they can have the liberty
and the courage to come forward and have
these kinds of conversations you know
that
kind of comfort i think is a real
important thing and
we've seen it in the past that sports
can often be a vessel
for broader societal conversations and i
think that's what's happening here
you